2016 Ерік був дружний червоних ким для с і на
уста йому тему роті сомики не умив і
жадібну щура то головну тему
стала сировини і вона актив на устілці
фрукти в неї км і стеля та сили
1 км і на байдужі дасть народжується з кого
народу ми мучив цей позов на нижчих
глобальний характер і кіпр і сотні в
сирі
ви просто піти в сиду ступні
дипломатичні канали
мати вона відвози на сам ширяє росії через
її роль у сирі та санкціями через тис
поки не схоже
протеїн від або цих ви ікла в брюсселі
у який продемонстрував їдете у
харчуванні санкцій проти Росії через
агресію в Україні на жаль не було
ніякого прогресу на і кумом йому брили
за знову ти рішення танцює та санкцій
там розум і ви вирішили продовжити і самці
протрузії що на шість місяців е100
кожного житлового компромісу з нідерландами
ще з барахти угоду про асоціацію з
україною
нідерланди сказав і не ратифікація суті
а тенор і френдами вкрити не там у
лідера з повод ідуть від ковою
документики бояр у світла страх і
волонтер прикладом чогось року просто п'ятьма
на місце теми пунктів про мій будь ні
членства в єс для його
якби він і так просто не так приймального
сина кіно там вчаться гаранту ще
європейський союз може пологів животи
формувати єдиний фронт просто
дестабілізують через зовнішню політику
росії g.na при цинковому у саміті з
swiss потрібні обійшлося і без такої
проблеми в с я до brexit двадцять сім
голів тремтіння в'їзд на формальні вечір
і обговорювали я на вигляд від м'язів і
процес британського приклад яка зумій
на неформальний зa стригти не запити ви